welcome to this video yen the man let's
see what we can do I don't have a good
score as described minus one and
displaying the Benoni of all openings
yeah okay hmm ok I'm going with that a
very classical line ok that's something
that I always wanted to study in more
detail but never really got around it ok
place with that f5 idea that's an
interesting way to play black gets
active active piece play with that oh
you don't know
ok let's probably right but I don't know
no it's not going it's not going for f5
immediately that's interesting I do this
maybe I wonder they work Gavin after
later f5 the bishop can't be somewhat
unstable but I don't know ok so Queen d2
does he really go be five then maybe
yeah maybe he does okay I'm not really
convinced that you can take the pawn no
he doesn't want to take the pawn just
night before so what is this next move a
hive I guess okay i'm trying to get
bishop age 6 in
yeah I'm always alone oh it's a bit
shaky against the Benoni adjust that
over years I've played almost
exclusively one Knight f3 which avoids
although some openings like the Benoni
the bangko and so on only in recent
years has started to play d for a little
bit more frequently it's not that I know
nothing but it's it's not really a
sufficient knowledge against a
well-prepared opponent Joe ff5 looks
like the most northern move here not
quite sure what's no it doesn't do that
young Bishop g5 maybe I looks
interesting squadron he doesn't have a
great reply ok I'm gladly trading that
off without the dark squared bishop the
Benoni is not not the same opening ready
or it's not them the dangerous
counter-attacking opening that is often
well now when everything goes right yeah
3 is not not ideal but I really had no
big alternative so let's go and we ship
f1 f1 wow that I'm then I'm taking that
opportunity fixing that pond them on b7
it wasn't necessary to go if I've but
definitely not not bad soon now here we
go f4 where is your counter play
now if he goes f6 the question is if I
can already go e51 or if this is
premature interesting question but I
don't really see a great movie anyway
what what is he playing next we can play
rook to you won easily maybe Queen Noor
in g7 a also cannot play I don't really
know that's a somewhat nightmarish
disposition hard to move anything ok so
it was really relatively speaking a good
a good choice so where do we continue
here I mean okay i can go with five but
i'm not totally sure how convincing it
is ok preparing a little bit more oh now
i can go with five let's do that it's
not hesitate him and at the end I'm
going to play the move anyway so yeah he
takes that but it really doesn't matter
much nitey form
now 90 60 probably sacrifice the
exchange that's all it's a funny funny
pollution get so many so many
interesting moves e6e will take player
five otherwise it would be very strong
if one one question is really i can just
go but should be to actually i hadn't
come on let's do that it's a bit Mick
maybe but it is simpler than than the
other continuations okay so taking here
and now I get these six are well we'll
get to is also pretty inviting let's do
this for possible night you form 94 okay
you can check with the knight on d5
okay that's not totally convincing okay
I'm spending too much time here while I
try to refute this this position but no
not sure how good it is actually I
probably had something better earlier I
mean this is not bad it just felt like
it should I'm should be should be over a
while already
yeah so he goes to age six and then I
take on be 70 why is that balance d
seven yd seven looks good
check i don't i see a win here because
i'm just too blind him I really don't
see when
I don't get Adam it's a no-win mm-hmm I
didn't see one I didn't see one
I mean that might win but it wasn't like
just check checkmate which really there
should be maybe he has no move check no
time I can check me here for Queen f1
mates I don't believe it obviously
didn't do it check check black 4 flex on
time Wow well I completely lost the
thread in that game yeah I round here
white white just win sir with good play
but I couldn't really prove it so what
is the best way to do it that's not even
the best move the engine gives Bishop g2
just preparing even more and only later
pushing yeah i mean ok i had this
opportunity maybe earlier but I came
here maybe 96 and when I saw the move
but I wasn't sure about this thing I
wasn't sure how convincing this is we
should be one Queen d1 Bishop c4 I am ok
this it is very strong but ok I couldn't
figure that out I really couldn't this
it seems that black can not hold this if
the engine gives plus 2 that should be
winning ok I couldn't figure that out i
also thought okay this is should should
keep a huge advantage ok which it does
but not the way I played it probably ok
95 the simple 95 is better just playing
this pollution air probably why not just
take that pawn
I was thinking that the FR would be
useful but it wasn't really okay okay it
stays it stays a win but I could I
couldn't really check can't really
figure that out so the ice winning Queen
takes and look everyone and okay that's
not really difficult yeah so this ok man
it wins as well but can just not as
quick and convincing and now okay now
now I have a very cute win with Queen f7
it's okay not with 10 something seconds
I just took that but that was a big
mistake because he had he had Queen SE
one year quality yeah check yeah and
draw the black is winning okay here here
and now no this is just made in channels
I mean that just made it would have been
a very cold shower there yes i know i'm
winning again so we have that was very
much influenced by the by the time
situation Wow okay well thanks for
watching